today three women are gonna cook for me
and i'm gonna choose which one i'm gonna
date based on their dish are you excited
to meet three sexy ladies yes i am
sweating right now
my name is kiona my name is alexandra my
name is vai my name is elia i'm from a
small town called trento in northern
italy it's very well known for like wine
and there's a bunch of cows around so i
was with someone until three months ago
and then
we broke up and the breakup was actually
quite hard and so actually getting back
into the
dating scene has been
man i feel like i've been rusty honestly
my name is alexandra catalano because i
am italian but i am from sherman oaks
california i like italian cooking
because my family's italian and i grew
up eating lots of homemade pastas and
and fresh foods some kale
i feel like that's a lot of kale we'll
save the rest for later this is the
secret sauce to all italian food when in
doubt add garlic
i'm gonna go on my tippy toast i don't
know if he's gonna like this this might
upset him he's a real italian person
this is chickpeas because i'm a
millennial and millennials hate gluten
so i did something that i think he might
hate but i didn't mean to i'm a healthy
lifestyle person and i have a food blog
and i'm a nutritionist so i like to take
foods that people love and make them
healthy so i made a kale pesto and i'm
doing it with a chickpea pasta which i
think will upset him but i want to show
him who i am and what i would cook and
if he doesn't like it i totally
understand
it looks awesome i mean presentation is
so colorful i love the the connection
with the green and the yellow i love
that they actually took the time to put
the little pistol pieces i guess by the
side of the dish wait till eat it oh god
you really hated it huh i was upset by
this dish oh
so it looks like pastel pesto con pizale
which is equivalent of a pesto pasta
with peas oh does he speak italian i
want him to whisper in my ear all night
girl
whispers posh delicious
say
i swear i should know what the name of
this is it looks like pesto but it's
it's like slightly more creamy than i
was expecting so i'm actually curious to
try what this source is it might just be
pistol i'll tell them
he's he sounds real sexy though he
really do
it looks like it's someone that cares
about presentation as a whole they care
about the way that they show up to the
ward i don't know why this kind of
reminds of someone that's like
vegetarian or vegan which to me is a
plus because i'm vegetarian it might be
just the fact that it's green but yeah
and i don't know why the peas remind me
of someone that's maybe slightly more
outgoing
this is going to hurt go alex
looks like he likes it
look it looks like he likes it
this is incredible the
sauce i can really feel the basil coming
out and it feels like it's actually like
basil that has been made into the sauce
recently i wonder if the actual sauce
has been handmade by them but it's
really really good that's in the back
see it confidence girls
get it together
i do wish one thing and that is slightly
more salt the sauce itself makes it
really stand out but there's a little
bit of a lack of salt that's what i said
when i tried it that's what i said when
i tried i was like you need some salt
honey hello my name is vi and i grew up
in pennsylvania i love italian food so
much i don't know if it was garfield or
just really loving noodles ever since i
was a kid but that's it's my favorite
food give me pasta and i'm happy my
stepdad is lithuanian for dad so my tete
he taught me how to cook when i was
really young okay now my trick for the
stock is that with the last like 30
minutes
i add a ton of
nutritional yeast here
okay and then i'm gonna put a little bit
more pepper on there oh my god
i made the all the noodles from scratch
and then it's like a cauliflower tomato
sauce with zucchini and bell pepper
mixed in thank you
this looks like fries but i don't think
it's rice because it's not quite italian
this looks really interesting i cannot
quite tell what it is to be honest i
don't know
but this might actually be a good sign i
see a lot of what i'm gonna call cheese
i'm not sure if it's cheese i think it's
cheese is that a
cheesy person
it actually does look really good i'm
looking forward to trying it
[Music]
so it's definitely not pasta it's more
of a cauliflower
well i mean the sausage yeah but no it's
like i mean but that's homemade pasta
and he said it's not possible he's an
italian man none of our pastas are gonna
be pasta let me try again
is it wrong that i like watching him
chew
i do like it it's slightly spicy but in
a way that's not overbearing which is
awesome is it a bad thing that i don't
know what this is yes sir
you don't know what it is no you're just
gonna enjoy it yeah it's kind of like
wait what do you bring i like that this
is someone that's complete that's like
cares about creating a unique experience
that that hits on many different points
this is totally something i created for
the whole day and like be satiated by it
okay okay i'm still trying to figure out
what this is this feels like the
complete package i'm so happy for you
my name is kiona i was originally born
in new york so growing up in new york
that's who i was raised around black
people and italians
we gonna put our love in this and make
it do what it do
[Applause]
for the carrots it's looking good i'm
not gonna fry you smell good today i
cooked an italian inspired stuffed red
pepper i think he's gonna think oh this
girl's got flavor this actually looks
awesome i think i'm gonna enjoy this
i'm winning this italian man it looks
like pepperoni
pepperoni confirmed this is actually
quite exciting to me yeah you should be
excited it's about to be a party in your
mouth
this sounds like someone that may be
busy on the go and like has a lot of
things going on and like they don't
really have a lot of time to actually
make food which
i'm like that too so yeah always busy
that is me
really hot
taste is incredible he loves it this is
incredible it's
so good
honey it's actually really really
freaking good really really freaking
good
oh my god
[Laughter]
the way in which she combines the
flavors is honestly a 10 out of 10. oh
my god why do i feel like i just want
american idol oh man this is actually
incredible i really i really want to
finish this this is someone that looks
good
tastes good yeah i'm actually really
excited about meeting this this card oh
god my heart is melting pepper girl wins
i love the way you put this together i
love the fact that you seem efficient
and flavorful i love that you went with
many different flavors which happen to
combine together really freaking well i
decided
you're you're literally a
light that shines into a room and like
everyone's like
like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank you buzzfeed
[Music]
that's my way